just in the last few moments this jury
of seven women and five men have reached
a verdict they've found el shafielshake
guilty on all eight charges of which he
was accused they found him guilty of
conspiracy to commit hostage-taking
resulting in the death of four american
citizens two journalists james foley and
stephen sotloff and aid workers kayla
mueller and peter kassig they've also
found him guilty of two wider charges of
which he was accused conspiracy to
provide material support to terrorists
and conspiracy to provide material
support to a designated foreign terror
organization that means that this jury
believes they've heard enough evidence
they've heard enough witness testimony
to believe that el shafiel sheikh was a
member of the so-called isis beatles
that group of british men who traveled
from london to syria to commit these
awful acts of holding 26 western
hostages including the british aid
workers alan henning and david haynes
before murdering them they believe that
al shafiel sheikh while not possibly
involved in the direct murder of these
individuals was certainly involved in
the hostage taking which led to their
killing
the families of those four american
individuals were in court all of them
were crying at the moment that that
verdict was read out the daughter of
british aid workers scottish aid worker
david haynes who went to syria to help
the plight of individuals there she was
crying incredibly loudly as that verdict
was read out those families have had to
endure the most awful two and a half
weeks of testimony they've had to go
through something no family should ever
have to go through videos were played in
court of their loved ones final moments
propaganda videos of beheadings which
those is beetles those so-called is
beatles who were known by that name they
were given that name by their captives
because of their british accents they
released those videos for propaganda
reasons they were played in court
there were also 10 hostages who were
held alongside those murdered
individuals who also gave evidence
during the course of this trial they
testified about random and regular
beatings waterboarding choking and it
wasn't just
the physical torture that these people
had to endure it was also the
psychological torment that they went
through just to give you one example of
the horror we've heard about over the
past two and a half weeks we were told
that the hostages were forced to fight
each other that they were told to get
dressed in smart clothes given the
impression that they would be released
only to be driven to another prison it
really has been incredibly harrowing for
these families but finally uh they say
they have some sense of justice in that
they
that al shafiel was brought to trial
here in the u.s he's now been found
guilty of all eight charges of which he
was accused